welcome to this video this is round for
the single cup rather shortly released
after round 3 but this time I'm yeah I'm
quick with covering that round which is
only finished about two hours ago yeah I
think about two hours ago so let's get
going I'm doing this a bit differently
than the first couple of videos because
now I have a little bit more time on my
hands I'm going to look at one game in
particular in more detail that will be
on Wesley so with white against Ronan
but I will also briefly show you the
other games um in this case really
briefly because on their world they
weren't that interesting have to be
honest they're the main game that I'm
going to feature is interesting and
really nice the other games hmm not so
much but let's have a look what happened
to get an idea about the full picture so
get recalled let's start with that now
we got an open Sicilian which is um
rather surprising as Giri is not a very
regular 1.e4 player he does play it but
not in the majority of cases and quite
often nowadays the open Sicilian after
96 is dodged in favor of the rosseau
demo in fact that's the reason why I'm
not playing this rash Nick often because
people always play be should be 50
anyway deform we now get this rash Nick
off now the starting position here where
white has that on the choice the typical
choice between 95 and Bishop takes f6 95
is the more strategically focused a
continuation and was chosen here by Gary
Bishop e7 and takes takes c3 for a while
c4 was all the rage there but it seems
that this is rob
dafeng nowadays at least doesn't seem to
travel like that much c3 is a tradition
online Carlton plate 97 which is a
sideline and and a line that has been
played really a lot by am mihalik rose n
confirm now i'm going to polish
grandmaster cosine curve is a very sharp
enterprising clay and he also has has
written a book on this fashion
eco-friendly s-97 they're quite a lot an
interesting continuation that normally
white answers like this and we have a
sharp game with the pawn structure being
somewhat damaged for example something
like this this this this is kind of
normal well black sometimes in a
situation like that even can consider to
Castle long rather sharp stuff but Giri
didn't go for that he went 92 we see
that he spent quite some time there so
probably it wasn't a continuation that
he was so familiar with that said he's
not a very frequent wonderful player
concentrated and now he doesn't have a
double pawn here blacks compensation for
them um slightly weakened structure is
the bishop am quite often we will get a
situation as we have it in the game or
the South Lincoln fields rather logical
white getting the night over 25 quite
often we will get a situation where that
night is going to be taken by the bishop
and then we've got opposite colored
bishops f6 again z2 in those kind of
structures I mean we see it in the game
here black when did before takes and
shortly afterwards we see if some trades
here and now cards and liquidated that
night now we get that opposite colored
bishop situation the only thing that can
happen is that black is getting into a
into a position where that bishop is
somewhat awkward here on that diagonal
putting some pressure on f7 this is not
so easy for the black Bishop the black
on g5 is a little bit yeah it's not
terribly bad just not fulfilling any
active function at the moment and this
is the only thing that black has to be a
little bit very of that he's not kind of
getting into a situation that he's got
lots of pressure on f7 but it didn't
happen in that game Carlton had
everything under control yeah be sure do
you wanna try to get there yeah the
problem was that this is failing to roxy
form or if you can root d7 it's also not
leading to much and here you have to
think about those kind of continuations
can be quite awkward for white so
ultimately nothing happened to him yeah
we had a couple of more moves and here
the game was drawn very correct game not
very exciting but rather correct let's
say from both sides I think one key
point really was very early when after
97 um Geary dodged that invitation to
get a very sharp position after the
caption that's it too it's just a little
bit a little bit too tame to get too
much on that level it is very safe
forever so he wanted to play a save game
probably so it worked out has to be
noted that giri has a great score
against cars i think he has one winner
no loss so it's not it's almost
important to keep those things in mind
um okay so let's go with MBR with white
against Hikaru Nakamura and we've got
124 why should i grab place every
opening move efore d4c for everything so
he had got d4 and that camera goes for
Kings Indian no it's basically showing
directly that is info file and we we
gotta fight that game was interesting
the only reason that is not featured as
a game of that round on is that the
other game was just just better um or
more spectacular however you want it i
think it's the natural choice as we will
see later ok the sameish variation with
92 and nakamura goes with c5 this is
believed to be best against the sameish
nowadays to get into a binary structure
one point of that baloney structure is
that the night only two is quite often
basically forced to move again as
otherwise you cannot get your bishop out
and the night on g3 is often as we see
attacked by this and this means that
wide loses the loses a lot of time white
structure that the pawn chain is very
healthy and and quite resilient but he
uses he lost he loses time and black
gets counter play like this and with f5
coming also note that Bishop d4 can be
quite a quite an interesting option by
white hands night f2 though so it's not
like winning material and there should
be 3 + f5 a key counter counter punch
for black and this kind of position
that's absolutely essential that you
have to play actively black cannot just
sit around and let wide reorganize
behind the spawn chain you have to
nibble at that pawn chain very very
quickly and for interesting looking at
that night and Queenie 8 trying to use
that so a precarious situation of the
e-file yeah and now all hell breaks
loose as pigs and e5 is played what a
mess yeah those pawns look completely
messed up and why this breaking through
in the center yeah Black has to take it
and then d6 you're getting this into the
game yeah I complete complete chaos it's
very difficult here to say something
reliable in the context of just covering
that game quickly with a couple of in a
couple of minutes it's just ultra
complicated one thing that I definitely
want to show us that
a couple of moves later here h3 was
played takes rook e1 and total created
us and that a couple of moves later
exactly here in this position 94
probably wasn't a great idea here the
computer points out the clear
improvement on Rashida graphs play which
is rookie to that seems to be really
strong that is to take on g2 with the
rook and King edgemont king and look AG
one is possible continuation this seems
to be really really really good for
white the computers on plus one point
something and basically claims that
white will win here that's maybe true
but it's difficult to to analyze kingi
king age seven look g2 for example yeah
this already it's very close that some
kind of sacrifice might work White is
attacking with with almost all of his
pieces and I shouldn't forget that and
he has got the dangerous d pawns on the
board um probably rookie 2 rookies would
have led to something really really
dangerous and maybe a win for MBL but he
didn't do that he played rook t1 and the
whole situation is entirely entirely
unclear check that trade however now
brings us nearer to an end game black as
a pawn up but the bishops are of
opposite color and we know that this
quite often will increase the drawing
probability again why does a pawn down
but its opposite colored bishop and the
way it went Ashley yeah we had this
traded and he even gave up that dead
upon yeah the point is that one white
wants in this types of positions is you
want the defensive set up that is
reliable and quite often it is the case
that one flank has to be kept by the
king and one flank has to be kept by the
bishop in this case he's basically force
thing black to push that forward and now
after King deform and b5 and King here
we see that Bishop and King they safely
blockade those ports they are not going
anywhere the picture is also able to
protect the B to pawn at the h2porn I'm
sorry so that if black marches with this
King all the way to the point we can
safely protect it with that bishop it is
despite two points down just a draw yeah
nothing more nothing less and they they
continued a little bit here but agreed
to draw even here yet solid role because
I there's absolutely no way for with
turnlock here what can check it out and
what what are you doing if you go here I
mean what can you do this and completely
locate everything off it's just the
total draw its opposite colored bishops
for you they quite often simply kill
kill the game off ok have a look at
Greece shocked Apollo and we have many
Sicilians in that event yeah that you
recognize that many more then we have
had in an earlier high-level events
where Belinda fences or other a 45
defenses against 1.e4 were dominant and
here we've got tons of Sicilian so that
sends really good news to part of here
playing the night oh of course yeah
Bishop e3 here by my grief chakra and
they flicked that repetition and now
Grisha of course avoids it yeah nobody
wants to repeat with white on goofy 71
with eight and three this is actually a
slight concession on white spot he says
okay okay I'm playing every first then
Bishop e3 but committing early to f3 has
some disadvantages as it basically tells
black already okay I'm going to play a
three no matter what because a
difference can be that
if you look at this it's not so clear
that why he needs the f3 for example
after you 60 can also go g4 here it's a
very sharp line or let's say I'm in some
situations here anywhere I can also
switch that's probably a bad spot but
let's say 96 so I'm sorry 96 this this
and then F for let's say and we are
still flexible when we don't play f3
that early okay but this is how it went
t5 and now visually six Bishop e3 and
now h5 yeah this is all the rage and
many Sicilians and the idea is really
very modern you know some years ago like
starting in the in the 1980s and 90s was
established that g4 is a very dangerous
continuation for one in many Sicilians
and nowadays the answer from a black is
simply to just dash out h5 before g4 is
even coming quite quite an interesting
approach I think in this particular move
order it makes quite some sense because
white whites plans with LG for are
somewhat limited g4 is not just an
attacking move and it is but it's not
just that it also has some strategic
ideas by pushing the night f6 away to
establish more control over D Phi for
example h5 is just cutting that
possibility completely g4 yeah 95 was
played occupying that central square
took it with the bishop you can also
take with the night this also has been
played before and seems to be okay from
like however here the move h5 I'm sorry
the move h5 it doesn't really help black
that much in this structure you'd rather
have it back because once this pawn
structure has changed avoids
less attractive okay took it with the
bishop and now 97 here blacks IDM
amongst others is to try to maybe put
some pressure on their part 22 g6 and
long not be 6 that's the idea yeah if
white go see for now he will have some
problems after rook c8 c4 is hanging and
d5 is hanging which means that yeah
something is going to fall that was
Griffiths choice yeah and now to pollen
just took their pawn it was quite funny
that after those moves Grigio sank into
deep thought and played 95 so let's
check check for us what's happening here
so King me one night bg5 as we said this
was played black hands one upon but make
no mistake he's far behind in
development white already has canceled
had time for rook be one king be 1 i'm
sorry and Lucas aunty one year after
long castles why definitely has
compensation Knight a5 taking that pawn
and yeah being flexible sometimes the
night might come to see for white has an
initiative for that part rook b8 covered
Bishop c4 yep gaining time on that on
that night night returned and now Bishop
f6 it seems that Bishop f6 is a moment a
key moment we're probably and whites
course has to be improved upon um maybe
um moves that simply continue the whole
thing without being too forcing were
more interesting for example the
computer suggests rook age to e 1 year
simply centralizing and keeping
everything keeping the tension if black
is castling now then white will have a
strong initiative with many moves
one thing that also on that always is in
this the move Bishop age six trying to
drive that look away and then do
something here also Bishop b3 dismay
quite some sense keeping that bishop on
the board and it is a strong diagonal
and asking blank again okay what exactly
is your next move yeah the rook AG one
has very safely prevented black t five I
think here White has definite pressure
for that for that porn that is given
after Bishop f6 11 we get some
simplifications and at the end this
slide let's say um yeah and from just
from looking at it optically let's say
it looks like why this bed is more
active but it's really nothing serious
roop do you three was played on look II
one this is good giant b5 king of eight
now is awkward we lose some material
yeah rook went back and the thing is you
may be already suspect what will happen
here we have got some trades now 94
opposite colored bishops again and here
it's the kids wear and absolutely
nothing happens early continued one or
two moves and now agreed to a draw so
not very exciting but rather again
rather correct game probably this Bishop
f6 move here when we jump quick back
quickly Bishop f6 in this position was
probably a little bit too simplistic to
go for something keeping the tension
with with Luke he1 looked look more more
promising okay so karana a lot let's
have a look at that game now the semi
sloth one main feature of wishes opening
repertoire for it so Korea really
he already had played that in 1991 it
was 24 years ago 1991 when he played as
candidates match versus Anatoly Karpov a
just very unlucky Lee lost yeah he was
dominating that match but ultimately
yeah correct under under the pressure
probably um back then even yet played it
so huge huge experience that aren't
hands with that opening kirmada goes
with Bishop g5 after which black has
some choice um I'm not actually I'm just
about her let me think about it last
year in december i think in the london
chess classics he played the move d
takes afford the one Vinick variation
and this was surprising because the port
phoenix still has slightly dodgy
reputation but chronic didn't get
anywhere and he knows his openings so an
interesting indication that maybe the
board winning isn't that fishy it's also
featured in a recent book by last
shunned or so maybe the Bob Vinick if
you are a little bit crazy and have time
on your hands you can try it h6 is the
more solid move after which white can
sacrifice a pawn with Bishop H form like
this the nth I Moscow gambit this is
because aged six is the Moscow variation
and Bishop f6 Queen f6 is the main line
again nowadays and here black is
basically trading the bishop pair
against flexibility in some space and
white in this game here went for a very
quick III for wider has to really
delicately um delicately right time his
his pawn breaks and then pawn structure
changing moves because black has the
bishop pair if you use your space and
open
the position in in some wrong way then
the bishop pair will be super important
in that in that tag of game but it's
interesting how I played it with you for
a queen d 8 but are not just retreating
and now rookie one was plain looking
very normal c5 very interesting yeah
Black is really saying okay I've got
that Bishop on g7 that is unopposed and
I'm not going to accept that you maybe
want to clamp down on me just for
example if a black is doing nothing
which is actually not that easy and say
you play something like that and just
imagine a position like that where white
would enjoy the space he has H form and
it's rather one-sided and he had c5 that
blasts opened the whole center and white
really doesn't have anything else and
taking 1c5 I really don't see any useful
alternative I mean white candle he took
that and then I'll see if I I'm sorry
but you have to take on c5 somehow yeah
it's a otherwise not not at this
happened I'm sorry I'm confusing things
I was thinking that white cakes and then
d force plate huh no it happened like
that but the thing is what black
achieved with that c5 break that Bishop
has a very strong useful diagonal takes
a digs and back-end Queen d6y a black
can be very satisfied yes bishops are a
wide open and um um yeah y tends to
think of being precise IAM and secure
equal chances um the thing is it's quite
funny that in that game again after some
moves that we get opposite colored
bishops yeah okay the position is is
very very equal ish in fact here and
wide maybe has a slight pool because the
bishop on d5 is
annoying but when you look at the game
in more detail which I won't do now you
will see that that slide slightly more
active Bishop is not enough to get
anywhere serious so we have a couple of
more moves they did put in some time but
ultimately this is not leading anywhere
and white seems to be a bit better but
there was no worm there's no wind to be
found funny like has that strong counter
play with the with the pawn down and
Jack will draw yeah Bishop e3 that
forces the draw check because this is a
pure perpetual this is Jack one way to
check on 2g two after which I merely to
is going to be the perpetual here yay
Jack and draw yeah so that also seemed
rather correct solid game here by corona
and and Anand I actually had a really
wrong recollection how that central
tension was resolved but ultimately the
key moment was in the opening that c5
moved that made sure that the bishop on
g7 actually has got something to do okay
so now let's go to the main game of that
video Wesley so with wide against level
Aronian yeah what opening to expect in
that game difficult because some Wesley
who is playing basically all moves on
move on yeah t for this time and we get
a new minion he goes for f3 this is
probably the sharpest line that has a
still sound reputation the same ish is
probably the sharpest with III but this
is some somewhat dodgy I mean I play it
quite a bit in my blitz games via the e3
water but objectively speaking it is
somewhat OG and f3 is them somewhat
modernized version of the sameish wear
white wants to grab that youth center
and if possible do that without wasting
a move on a three-hour own young goes
with c5 this is a move that I've got
lots of simply sympathy for of course
because it's the move then I also have
in my book d five castles ephone d6 yes
it was interesting for me to see that
Aronian is playing that this is one of
the lines that i have in my book I have
from in this position I have both be
five and i give thee six as the somewhat
less um chaotic alternative after be
five and then Blumenfeld star white has
the moon's 'if I've and this after 98 f
4 is really leading to crazy
complications the d6 line however is a
little bit more I mean you cannot call
it solid but at least let's say it's a
little bit less dependent on knowledge
of concrete lines you get a
strategically sharp position here and
not so much a position that really has
to be calculated move by move as it is
with the b5 line where your lousy five
um Wesley plate night g2e to now which
is probably the main continuation after
Bishop d3 which looks a little bit more
natural actually em to get this and
black can play and we'll play b5 this is
a delayed b5 pawn sacrifice it leads to
really good play for black now in many
cases black would have a huge initiative
it's especially important for wise not
to be too greedy if you take stuff here
yeah things like that then black will
have a tremendous compensation for that
note that f3 is
absolutely not well suited in this kind
of position I think of c4 Bishop c5 or
queen to be six what is that King saying
about all this white has to be careful
92 and said the main move the move
Bishop d2 is interesting and was played
last year in a game between Nakamura
with white & Carlson the reason why I'm
mentioning it is that probably the best
reply to that move is takes takes Knight
age 5 which funny enough aronia had on
the board about ten years ago so they
have some relation to that line the the
players and this is the wrong yet I had
some experience from the white side 92 l
said was played and now in my book I
have the standard moved there be five
again sharp pawn sacrifice after which
white has basically figured out after a
while that taking in the porn isn't a
good idea so the main worthless night f4
yeah attending also to take only six and
T I think leg is ok with both a six what
I have in my book and he takes d5 which
was played earlier this year I think in
the in the in the Norway chance event
white Apollo was black against Grisha
with the wind at the end as I said my
move in the book is a six which is just
delaying that capture for one moment but
it leads to the same thing yeah a 611
was played by level of interesting move
the ideas that after possible he takes
d5 see takes d5 we are ready to push b5
so in many cases a useful move a force
plate I would have been really reluctant
to play that it looks I know it doesn't
feel right to me to weaken the queenside
like that and give black that that yeah
safe and comfortable
Bishop position but maybe it was a
necessary thing to do bring black haired
b5 up his sleeve to be honest I'm rather
skeptical of the white position here in
general it's not very well developed and
black has possibilities to get active
quickly and we see one of them Bishop f5
that's a funky little move intending b5
again yeah it's not so easy to
understand but if you let's say white
place moves like that then be five an
interesting possibility because this and
this um now k Bishop e3 is maybe a bad
bad way to to show it and he went Bishop
detour let's say you way you go here
right then be five is the move and takes
takes and now Bishop c3 is threatened
with check now that's one point of that
Bishop move to a five yeah Bishop d2 was
played probably for that reason now be
five is really just losing upon takes
and takes and now night edge file
remember that early idea from that game
that Ronan had with white ok this is
very similar now we have AG 92 and
Bishop f5 and the a pawns and so did but
the idea is the same the quick night age
5 is intending to things that really
disturbing check on h4 and the second
thing is pawn to f5 trying to crack open
that center we should never forget that
it's all about checkmating the
opponent's king and what is White's King
doing only one yeah he's not safe blacks
king is the much safer much safer piece
him some a dangerous situation already
for white after nine inch file he went
g3 that's understandable him Queen edge
for is pretty awkward g3
97 if black tries to go f5 he has to
reckon with taking piece takes and g4
however queen age 4 will be rather
strong so probably Bishop g2 not taking
as g4 has no follow-up and here after
takes and takes I think the position is
about equal f5 was an interesting
alternative i wronged you never went 97
why not Bishop g2 trying to use that g3
move to some to give it some kind of
purpose and here we go b5 yeah what
happens now if white takes that and
things here johnny has to get the King
out in the open not a good idea so it's
not just a pawn grab let's say after
after b5 so what did he play what did so
what did so player though as tricky I
used that so good rather often anyway
and now one of the players is actually
called so difficult stuff yeah what did
he do what did Wesley players over my
say westlake well um what did he play he
went for g4 and I understand that this
night was immensely annoying when age 5
but I think after g-form blacks um yeah
blacks position gets very very very good
and especially from a practical point of
view it is hellish to play what what now
happens probably you should have been a
bit more conservative let's say with
with castling deform and back and now
black can do them some things we should
be six with that intention I mean I'd
rather be black here because whites
pieces seem rather uncorrelated if we
check all that it kind of is not working
together
but still it doesn't look like white is
falling apart in a couple of moves after
g4 however it's a different scenario and
before night went back yeah if white
takes then check like we'll get
something back here and again still
after 95 and then f5 will have a very
strong initiative form um what is only a
pawn yeah so nothing nothing much in
particular night be one was played here
immediately however check check King
everyone yeah and here if we look at
this position which is a key position
really um it's important to not be too
materialistic here we are playing for an
attack on Wyatt's king and a move like
let's say night H back to f6 is simply
awful yeah we don't want to lose that
time while in particular gets in Bishop
you want here but it's not so much about
the concrete move but about the spirit
in which you have to play if white is
doing all those wacky things yeah night
was developed it has to go back yeah you
have the King in the F file somewhere in
the middle and everything looks kind of
uncoordinated what you have to do is
check the most aggressive continuations
and trying to open up the position
towards the king the move that aronian
plate is strong I was also thinking that
f5 might be a continuation I mean I let
me show what the one he did ironia
played 95 he offered sacrifice that
night it's a good move I was thinking
before I looked at 95 that f5 might be
an interesting move the idea said after
the night capture we do this and this
looks really really bad them that that
King would have won the open FR now
better not it's much better to take f5
for example you with the pond and then
again 95 is an interesting option after
y takes Knight f3 leads to a fantastic
attack that is probably decisive there
were many interesting at attacking
possibilities but the move 95 as played
by our own ian is strong so we don't
need to look for an improvement it just
that they were interesting alternatives
that can be explored um yeah I think
that here probably um white should have
taken that night on age five it does not
seem to lead into a force loss for white
and if that is not the case you probably
should grab some material for your
suffering um he played Bishop you one
but let's have a quick look that at this
here and then f5 of course and we have
to break open the position we need a
rook on the F file and play yeah and now
after f5 Bishop you want maybe pushing
that back Queen back and then f4 is it
move that the computer suggesting is a
typical line which is a kind of crazy
but we see that White's King is under
and a huge in huge trouble and probably
in a practical game it will be difficult
but white probably had to do that just
grab that piece and hope for the best he
went Bishop be one after which Queen f6
was played now it took that piece and
Knight f3 yeah and now we see that this
is a very awkward situation black and
threatening all kinds of discoveries
with that night why doesn't have much
choice he has to play Bishop f2 yeah and
here I'm not totally sure but I mean
it's a matter of how much time you want
to invest when you look at this game
aronian play to move Bishop g4 which
leads to a very dangerous
initiative and maybe it also is winning
somehow but it's um yeah I cannot be
ignored that Queen takes be to just
grabbing that thing and grabbing the
rook next was a good continuation yeah
Bishop takes Queen a1 and the queen is
not a cut off from blacks Cabot can
return I think black is probably better
here by quite some um yeah back back
quite some margin but I understand that
Aronian rather wanted to continue the
attack on the King Bishop g4 it seems
that there is no clear-cut offense but
um at least them white could have put up
a huge resistance I believe with 92 in
this position for example after Knight
d4 there's a5 activating that Bishop on
g2 after Queen takes if I for example
pigs pigs 93 why this holding on it is
not fun black as better but it's not a
direct loss fam the way it went it was a
direct loss Quincy one and now strong
move 94 get double attacking here and
basically forcing a trade on d4 after
which the C file gets opened up black is
the piece down but White's coordination
is absolutely awful 'if I've yet trying
to get some space and takes 92 whoopsie
8 yeah gladly will use the half-open
file Queen to be one and now how is this
to be finished very nicely played by
Ronan now he played to move b3 just
pushing that point forward the idea is
to get that entry square on c2 if Y
displaying a nothing moves we would go
rook c2
and probably just win the game in short
order this is why white took that 93 and
Bishop b6 this has a clear purpose
looking at f2e 5 was played and he
aronian had the opportunity to finish
the game off a little bit quicker than
it happened in the in the game the move
Roxy to was a very spectacular solution
here very nice we are threatening mate
and yeah what can why do I mean if you
try to cover that you get hit with this
so what are you doing probably taking
then d3 is everything and look at this
here and visually too and this means
that white is losing huge chunks of
material he has to give them the Queen
and can try to struggle from here but it
will probably not lead to anything much
black is winning yeah the Roxy to was a
very spectacular way to end it but
Aronian just went to a 7 which is
totally fine of course it will win the
black attack is too strong those pieces
here are our tight down there pinned or
they are sitting in the corner in case
of the loop on edge one without having
any particular purpose and black is
attacking with almost all of his pieces
so ok King to g1 Bishop f5 and push it
before check check King f1 and Queen f4
and here Wesley resigned the point is
and problem is that if white takes on f5
which seems very normal looking then d3
will lose the house they will actually
be checkmated in short order or white
loses some basically everything so a
nice attacking game here by Livan it
seems that he is
back in shape in that event he had a
very nice win in the first round against
the Koala and now again nice we near
with the black pieces out of an Enzo
line that I really have some sympathy
for I think black seems to be okay and
in practical games quite often the
activity that you get and that nims will
be known is structured if you think
about that night h5 movie this idea that
then f5 this is very active enterprising
play and it is allowed by this
non-symmetrical c5 based way of playing
against f3 yeah this was round four of
the sink world cup for games that
featured opposite colored bishops and
unfortunately not very exciting games on
however so with white was the wrong I
think was very nice good effort by
Aronian round five and is played on the
Thursday um and this time I'll be doing
the live commentary for the internet
chess club the ICC together with
grandma's the last beau handsome I'm
really looking forward to that it's a
very nice job to have ya looking at
those games and trying to explain what's
going on especially if you have such a
competent term and that is this partner
if you are a member of the eyes you see
make sure to join us where we will be
much fun I will still do a game of the
day or round recap I have to call it
video after that it will be relatively
late German time but what can you do
just look forward to that going to cover
around five in the same way I covered
round for you ok guys thanks for
watching